[Music]
first question can a poor country
reasonably aspire to become a
high-income one within a few years
second question how much time would they
really need and ferb question how would
they do it dear viewer these are some of
the most common questions send us here
on this channel we've seen in various
videos how several countries have
managed to change their luck and become
locomotives well Divya in this video I
want to tell you about a very particular
case I want to tell you about Poland's
because Poland's becoming something of a
new Germany well listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
here's a question for you and as always
please do not google list which do you
think is the city with the most polish
inhabitants Warsaw
maybe Cracow well wrong actually it
would be Chicago two million polish
people live in Chicago yes we are really
not kidding here dear viewer it's not
been easy for poles during the Second
World War Poland was the country that
suffered the most no less than one out
of every five poles that's almost 6
million people which is the conservative
estimate by the way lost their lives and
after that disaster they endured 44
years of a communist government who in
addition to exerting an enormous amount
of political repression also left them
as a poor country
in 1989 when this system came to an end
Poland's per capita income was between
three and five times smaller than that
of developed countries such as Italy
France or the United Kingdom but just
hold on a second because things they've
really changed
[Music]
Poland's a country located halfway
between Paris and Moscow and has 40
million inhabitants completely changed
its model and since they've done this
their economy has grown by over four
percent every year all right so now you
might be thinking did I just put too
much emphasis on 4% a year because it
doesn't sound that impressive I mean
this is especially if you compare it to
the pretty crazy growth rates that you
can see in the Asian Tigers 4% kinda
sounds like a joke right well folks if
you are thinking that you are missing a
couple of important details
the first is that we're talking about
almost 25 years of uninterrupted
economic growth here not even the great
crisis of 2008 and 2009 really affected
this country at all we could say the
Poland's moving kind of like a giant
cargo ship it's not the fastest ship on
the water for sure but it has moved an
incredible distance
[Music]
put another way young Polish people have
pretty much no idea what an economic
crisis is alike the second detail is
also very important here because unlike
what happens with the Asian Tigers
opponent has had this huge growth while
being a consolidated democracy and by
the way that really kind of dispels an
important myth here and that's that
countries need a strong hands in order
to grow well anyway thanks to this
growth Poland has had an amazing 25
years this country has gone from having
average salaries of between 10 to 15,000
American dollars per month to having a
per capita income taking into account
each country's price difference this in
2018 will be higher than that of Greece
Portugal and every latin-american
country and the reality is it's also not
really that far behind Spain or Italy
either but having gotten to this point I
think there's a question that we really
need to answer how did they achieve this
well listen up because that's what we're
going to talk about in today's video
[Music]
[Applause]
the end of an era
for 44 years from 1945 to 1989 the
socialist state of the People's Republic
of Poland a satellite country of the
Soviet Union was in power by the way to
give you an idea of how great Moscow's
control was it said that when in 1950
the Polish leader Bala slaw Beirut
showed Joseph Stalin himself a draft of
the future polish Constitution that the
leader of the Soviet Union made dozens
of corrections by hands which of course
were taken into account
anyway the Polish regime was one of the
least harsh in the entire Soviet orbit
for example most of the lands wasn't
collectivized the Catholic Church was
allowed to function with relative
freedom and even though political
repression was high it wasn't quite as
intense as was in other countries even
though of course as in any good
socialist country the state controlled
almost everything and in 1989 its
economy completely shattered now thanks
to all these small freedoms a real
political opposition emerged led among
others by lack of Al Unser the leader of
the Independent Solidarity union the
first free union of all Eastern European
countries thanks to this when the soviet
union's power began to crumble Poland's
became the first country in Eastern
Europe to set its political transition
in motion to completely abandon
communism and so on during the fourth
1989 the first relatively free elections
were held and with that was no turning
back
[Music]
shock therapy
just a few months after the first
elections in September of 1989 the
Minister of Finance
lesyk Val tsarevets sets a plan on the
table to extend the entire communist
fabric and replace it with a capitalist
model
three months later this shock therapy as
it's been known as launched Poland
exerted a liberal program called shock
therapy the idea was either the patient
improves or dies from one day to the
next
everything was liberalized in a very
rigid and centralized economy in which
prices and needs had nothing to do with
reality he called it the lunar economy
everything was fiction
Peter Pina genia Osinski polish diplomat
suddenly everything changed
prices were liberalized controls were
lifted people were able to set up
private businesses they stopped printing
money the economy began to open up to
the world and the plan was launched to
privatize public enterprises
[Music]
so within a short time not even the
polls could recognize Poland's also the
government's had a very clear idea about
the future Poland needed to get as far
away from Russia as possible and
strengthen its ties with the rest of
Europe and the United States so as the
result of all of this well a few years
later they joined both the European
Union and NATO now what model do you
think the country has followed since
then
[Music]
change of course now we've already told
you plenty of times the world is getting
better
poverty is decreasing and countries are
getting richer but despite this
belonging to the club of rich countries
is still a difficult mission even so
everything points to Poland achieving
this within a very short amount of time
dear viewer this country is becoming
Eastern Europe's Germany
[Music]
[Applause]
see Poland has become an industrial
powerhouse flooded with multinationals
and like in Germany had small and
medium-sized companies have begun to
cross the border the result since 1989
its foreign trade has multiplied by more
than 25 Polish exports amount to almost
two hundred billion dollars per year
which represents more than 40% of the
country's GDP which is a seriously high
number
[Music]
this simply explains why polish roads
are full of trucks so now you must be
wondering well how are they achieving
all of this what on earth is the key to
their success
well Divya take note here the Polish
recipe has four main ingredients first
the establishment of institutions that
attract a lot of foreign investment
vehicle security property rights ease of
setting up companies and competition for
example 14 special economic zones have
been created where any interested
company can gain many advantages second
strict controls of public accounts
Poland's government is one of the most
healthy in the European Union public
debt for example is barely 50% of the
GDP and almost as importantly since 1989
they have been set on fighting inflation
so no printing bills to finance the
government's basically the opposite of
countries like Argentina third quality
education yep you heard that right
Poland has managed to make their
educational system work and they've done
it without wasting huge amounts of money
it's rate of university students is
higher than the average of the European
Union nine out of ten young people
complete secondary education and
according to international studies the
Polish education system is one of the
ten best not just in Europe but in the
whole world and fourth does moderate
taxes for example companies are taxed
19% while small companies are taxed 15
and income tax breaks down into two
brackets eighteen percent for the first
twenty four thousand and thirty two
percent for the rest
[Music]
and in addition because Poland is a
fairly conservative country families
have even more advantages so if we take
into account both personal taxes and
pension payments Poland is the fourth
oacd country where families pay less
direct taxes so it's with these four
ingredients that Poland has managed to
become Eastern Europe's Germany and
export and industrial power with a
healthy government and a quality of life
that just keeps on growing the best
proof of this is perhaps that within a
few years the great power of the East
has gone from being a country of
emigrants to a country of immigrants
[Music]
from a country of emigrants to a country
of immigrants in recent years if
something has characterized the Polish
economy it's the simple availability of
work unemployment is approaching 6% and
many companies are beginning to have a
problem finding workers initially
foreign companies would only look for
highly experienced employees with titles
now they take everyone and give them a
month of training if necessary Roman
entrepreneur and of course if
companies need a lot of workers and
can't find them all wages go up the
average gross salary in the first
quarter of 2018 was 7.1 percent higher
than in the same period in 2017 average
gross salary exceeds 1,400 per month the
Central Statistics Office of Poland and
do you know what this situation is led
to well first many young poles who until
recently left on master rich European
Union countries now are deciding to stay
and second in recent years more than 2
million Ukrainians have settled in
Poland especially young people looking
for better opportunities than the ones
they could find in their country of
origin
this means the Poland's now has more
people arriving than leaving now as we
always their visual politic not
everything is so great Poland is facing
quite a serious aging problem and the
Law and Justice Party a very nationalist
and very conservative party won every
recent election and now controls the
country some of their decisions have
caused the European Union to threaten
Poland's with sanctions and even
suspends their rights as a member but
that's something we're going to address
in a future video now it's your turn do
you think Poland's would be a good
example for Cuba or with the Chinese
model actually be better well we'll
leave your answer in the comments
section below as well as in this survey
and I really hope you enjoyed that video
if you did please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos also do not forget to check out
our friends of the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode though and are mine and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]